[Music]
foreign
so today is going to be a pretty
important lecture this is where we are
going to derive from scratch the
simplest differential equation uh x dot
equals Lambda X or the derivative of x
with respect to time is proportional to
X okay and we're going to derive this
with a very simple example of the
population of bunnies growing in the
wild we're going to solve this we're
going to write down what the solution is
for X as a function of time and I'm
going to kind of walk you through a
number of other examples of where this
kind of really simple differential
equation comes up so if you um you know
need to brush up on your Calculus you
can go check out uh some of the previous
videos kind of the review of calculus
but at this point you should be pretty
comfortable with taking derivatives and
writing down how things change in time
as DX DT okay so I'm going to start uh
with one of my kind of favorite uh
examples which again is population
Dynamics I think that's a really
intuitive example of this simple linear
differential equation so we're going to
say that we have some bunnies let's say
we have some buddies let us say
uh that bunnies
what do bunnies love to do
bunnies love to procreate let's say that
bunnies are
procreating
at a prodigious rate so they are growing
uh more and more and more that's what
bunnies do if you have a couple of
bunnies soon you'll have more than a
couple of bunnies and then you'll have
way too many bunnies
um so we have some bunnies
and specifically we're going to write
down this as a mathematical problem so
we're going to say that the bunny
population
the bunny
population
is the variable X so X is literally
going to be you know how many bunnies I
have the bunny population is X
and
the population grows the population
grows
now you would assume that the population
of bunnies grows proportional to how
many bunnies there are okay so if I have
a few bunnies that few bunnies they're
going to have you know baby bunnies
proportional to how many there were
originally and if I have a hundred times
as many bunnies to start with then I'm
going to have a hundred times more baby
bunnies right so the um the population
grows at a rate that is proportional to
the size of the population of X so the
population grows at a a rate and we're
going to call this rate Lambda
proportional
proportional
to the population size
to the population size
and this is actually all we need to
write down a differential equation okay
so the bunny population is X and the
population grows at a rate Lambda
proportional to the population size what
that means is the rate of change the
population grows the rate of change of
the population in time I'm going to
write this down
the rate of change DDT
of the population X DX DT the rate of
the change of population X bunnies with
respect to time it grows or shrinks in
time
and the amount to which X changes is
proportional to the population size at a
rate Lambda
so Lambda is essentially the birth rate
given you know x amount of bunnies
Lambda times x is how many baby bunnies
are born kind of at a constant rate okay
and so this is whenever you see an x dot
here
um kind of we just Define DX DT to be we
call that x dot okay so dot is a special
symbol we use to refer to the change of
something in time so x dot equals DX DT
and just by you know writing down a word
problem kind of our choice in modeling
this population of bunnies is that we're
saying that the the number of baby
bunnies is going to be proportional to
the number of current bunnies so the
number of baby bunnies the rate of
change in my population is proportional
this Lambda is just a number could be
five it could be two it could be 1.02
times the current population X okay
um
now okay whenever I write down a
mathematical model you should be
thinking to yourself how useful is this
model uh are there things I'm leaving
out of the model that are really
important and how much harder would my
life be if I included those extra terms
in the model so for example we know that
bunnies are not Immortal they do in fact
die so there is also a death rate you
know a minus D times x that in principle
should be proportional again to the
population size of those bunnies so
Lambda you know is the growth rate maybe
Lambda is actually the growth rate minus
the death rate okay that would be
another constant that we could call
Lambda now there might be Predators
there might be wolves that are eating
those bunnies I'm not including any of
those other Dynamics here but we will
very soon in the next few lectures we're
going to start building up how do we add
more assumptions and make this a more
realistic model and make this a richer
differential equation but for now this
is a pretty good model if you just have
a big big open field or forest and you
drop down 10 bunnies very soon you'll
have 20 bunnies and soon after that
you'll have 40 bunnies and then 80 and
so on and so forth until you know
something else happens like they eat all
the food or Wolves or foxes come in and
start eating them so this is a pretty
good model for now
and so uh the
the question we're going to ask is what
is the population as a function of time
so what
is the population
as a function of time as a function
of time
and specifically that is you know this x
is the population of my bunnies and it
is a function of time so I might want to
you know plot
X as a function of time and again we
have this intuition that bunnies are
going to kind of grow and grow and grow
exponentially so we guess that it's
going to look something like this as
time goes on this population is going to
explode but how do I actually solve for
x of T given this differential equation
so that's what I'm going to do right now
we're going to solve this differential
equation we're going to kind of relate
that to our intuition and then I'm going
to give you some more examples
good so um I think what I want to do is
I want to
um solve this differential equation
and there are actually a number of ways
we can solve this so in this lecture and
in the next few lectures I'm actually
going to give you two or three or four
different ways of solving this
differential equation but for now we're
just going to use basic calculus things
you you totally already know okay so
um I'm literally just going to call this
you know method
one okay the method one solution there's
like four of these and so we're going to
start with uh DX DT
equals Lambda X and I always ask my
students in a live lecture you know what
are some ways to solve this differential
equation
so some of the students might say well
guess the solution I think the solution
is exponential growth you probably told
me that the solution is exponential
growth I could guess that that's fine
um usually at least some of my students
say well separate the variables and
integrate so that's what we're going to
do is we're going to take this DX DT and
we're going to split this differential
we're going to multiply both sides by DT
and then integrate both sides so we're
essentially
going to get
um
what am I going to do I'm going to
multiply both sides by a DT and I'm
actually going to divide both sides by X
to get all of my x's on one side and all
of my T's on the other so this is going
to be DX over X
equals Lambda DT
and now I can integrate both sides of
this so I can integrate both sides of
this
and essentially we know you know from
again basic calculus that the integral
of DX over X is the logarithm of X okay
so I'm going to say maybe I'll write
little arrows here this implies
kind of The Next Step
is that if I integrate both sides I get
the logarithm Ln
of X of T and I'm going to write X
explicitly as X of T it's a function of
time sometimes I'll drop that of T you
know here this is X of T okay this is DX
of T this is Lambda X of T at every time
this is still true at every instant in
time this this relationship is still
true you're one of the bunny population
year two year three this relationship is
still true okay so I integrate both
sides integral of DX over X is log of x
integral of Lambda DT equals Lambda t
plus a constant very important you need
that plus a constant okay and this could
be any arbitrary constant the reason is
is because if I differentiated both
sides any constant I add here plus 5
plus 10 plus 20 that goes away when I
differentiate so when I integrate both
of these sides there is a plus constant
that pops out technically there's a plus
constant on both sides but I'm just
going to lump it into this one here
okay and then kind of the last step this
is actually pretty easy so you've all
done this before in your Calculus class
is now again we want to solve for x of T
we don't want log of x of T we want X of
T and so the way we get X of T is we
take e to the both sides we exponentiate
both sides because log and exponential
are inverses so e to the log of x is
just X
so X of t
equals e to the Lambda t
plus a constant
and one of the cool things about
exponential functions is that I'll just
write this up here e to the a plus b is
equal to e to the A
times e to the B
and so I can take this expression here
and I can write this as
e to the Lambda T times e to the
constant c e to the Lambda T times e to
the constant c and e to a constant is
just another constant I'm just going to
call that k
okay so what I've done is we have
derived this differential equation that
governs bunny population growth we have
solved this differential equation using
very simple calculus we literally just
you know multiplied both sides by T DT
divided by X to get the x's on one side
and the t's on the other we integrated
we found that we get a log of x on one
side so we exponentiate both sides and
we get X of T is e to the Lambda T times
a constant okay that is the solution of
this differential equation
and so now the only question remaining
is you know what is this constant K and
typically you would get this constant K
by measuring what is the initial bunny
population at Time Zero or time one or
time two if you don't measure your bunny
population at some point in time you'll
never know kind of what x of T is
because it could be scaled by a constant
K it could be 100 times or it's always
going to follow this this exponential
Trend in time but depending on the
initial bunny population it could be
bigger or smaller and so generally what
you have is you don't just have this
differential equation x dot equals
Lambda X you also have some initial
condition X at Time Zero okay so X at
time 0 is my initial
population
size
and so if I if I plug that in here I say
x at time 0
equals
e to the zero e to the Lambda times zero
times K and e to the 0 is 1. so this
means that
sorry my my pens are squeaky K this
constant here is just my initial bunny
population size so this constant here is
literally my initial size of my
population of bunnies I'm going to draw
that right here so at time 0 this point
here is X naught my initial bunny
population and from there my population
is going to grow exponentially in
forward time as time goes on my
population is going to grow which means
the base of my population is bigger
which means it's going to grow faster
which means it's going to get bigger
it's going to grow faster get bigger and
so on and so forth okay
and so maybe I'll just write out the
full solution here
is that X of T equals e to the Lambda T
times my initial bunny population X
naught
this is the solution
of my first order simple ordinary
differential equation x dot equals
Lambda X okay
really really simple to write down
differential equations and to solve them
okay so what I'm going to do for the
remainder of this lecture is I'm going
to actually remind you what
is this funky e uh constant here what is
this this e the base of the natural
logarithm because I think a lot of you
might not remember what that is from
calculus you probably know how it works
you know how to do these integrals you
know that log and exponential are
inverses but I want to remind you kind
of refresh your gut intuition for what
is this exponential then I'm going to
give you a ton more examples of systems
that are governed by this kind of of
dynamics of x dot equals Lambda X we
call this a
first order I'll write this down we call
this a first order
first order
linear
ordinary
Orden ordinary
differential equation okay so first
order means that there's only a single
derivative DX DT there's no second
derivatives or third derivatives or
fourth derivatives there's no D squared
x DT squared it's just a first order
means DX DT
linear means that the way that X changes
in time is linearly proportional to X
this is just a number a constant Lambda
if this was DX DT equals x squared that
would be non-linear so linear means that
this equals you know a constant times x
it's linearly proportional to the state
of the system X
and ordinary just means that my my state
X only depends on a single independent
variable time so I don't need to take
partial derivatives I don't need to have
X doesn't depend on you know multiple
independent variables like T and Q and P
and things like that okay so there's
only one variable that X depends on and
so this is the simplest differential
equation it is first order it is linear
and it is ordinary and it has a very
very simple solution
in fact I'm going to show you in the
next lecture that this magic function e
to the Lambda T this special function
here you can actually derive it its
Taylor series as the solution of this
differential equation so so all of our
favorite functions exponential
logarithms Sines and cosines
those were essentially created because
they are the solutions of very very
common first order linear ordinary
differential equations okay
and we're going to talk about what is e
and then we're going to give you some
more examples so stay put
okay we're back
so we just uh derived this differential
equation for the population of bunnies
and solve this differential equation and
now we're going to ask ourselves the
question what is
what is this e this this uh kind of
Euler's number e so just a general rule
of thumb anything that has this Euler's
name on it is a huge deal in math so
Euler's function uh number e is like one
of the most important numbers in all of
math up there with pi and one okay so
it's a big deal and so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to derive e in a very
simple
example so a lot of us when we're taught
about the exponential function and how
exponential growth works we are taught
this in the context of uh like finances
and investing and compound interest okay
so kind of Economics is actually one of
the the cool and very intuitive areas
where this this special number e and
this function e to the T come up pretty
often so that's what I'm going to use to
motivate this okay
uh so what we're going to do is we're
going to just assume that we're
borrowing some money so uh let's say
let's
say I borrow
uh money I borrow money
to buy a new car okay I need a new car
to buy
a new car maybe a used car but a car
that is new to me in case I am going to
borrow money to buy a new car
and uh let's say that the
annual interest rate is R the annual
interest
rate
is r
okay so the annual interest rate is r
then if my interest gets compounded at
the end of every year then I would
basically have my initial loan amount X
at year zero right now I borrow x amount
of dollars at Time Zero and at year one
at the end of one year exit time one
is going to equal one plus r
times that number okay so this is
literally my initial
loan and this is my loan
after
one year
and this is what would happen if your
loan uh interest was compounded annually
at a rate R okay so maybe I borrow five
percent you know I borrow a a loan with
with five percent interest rate and so
after one year I pay 1.05 times that's
how much I owe of my initial loan amount
now at the time of filming this lecture
at least in the U.S our interest rates
have risen at a rate that is I think the
highest in the last 50 years so this R
is much bigger than it was even one year
ago which is not great if you need to
borrow money
uh but anyway this is how it works if
you compound annually
but banks are smarter than this they're
not going to give you uh they're not
going to let like loan you money at an
annual compound rate what they're going
to do is they're going to compound it
more continuously let's say they they
want you to have this rate R but instead
of compounding at the end of the year
they're going to compound every month
okay so let's see what this would look
like so this is
um let's say yearly
let's see what it would look like if it
was monthly
okay so if they compounded monthly
what you would have is you would have
again x 0 my initial loan amount
but now what we're going to do is we're
going to take this R and we're going to
divide it by 12 okay because we're you
know we're going to take this rate r
that was annual and divide it into 12
pieces so we're going to have one
plus r over 12.
but now we're going to multiply you know
in January I have 1 plus r over 12. in
February I take that amount times 1 plus
r over 12 because that little teeny bit
of interest that I now owe from January
that gets there's interest on that in
February and that one over one plus r
over 12 from January and February that
gets interest in March and in April and
in May and so you take this to the 12th
power okay and this might seem like a
pretty small difference we're actually
going to you know show in uh we're gonna
compute these and show that they're not
that different but this is a little bit
bigger than this because all of that
interest from January gets compounded in
February and that gets compounded in
March so there's a teeny little bit
extra that the bank is going to get if
they compound monthly
okay so that's X at year one still now
why stop there you know banks are
notoriously clever at getting uh your
money so what if they compound daily
okay so daily compounding again this is
pretty easy we're going to compute this
this is x 1 equals one plus r over 365
days in the year to the 365 power times
x naught now this might seem like a lot
of effort but they do this
electronically and this is where this
exponential function comes in again this
is a little bit bigger than monthly
compounding which is a little bit bigger
than yearly compounding because now
every day that little bit of Interest
gets you know is the base for the
interest that I accrue on the next day
okay and so
um being very clever banks have figured
out that the smartest thing you can do
is you can compound this continuously
every microsecond every plonk instant
the bank is compounding the interest
that you made on the last microsecond or
tiny little plonk instant or nanosecond
and so kind of in the natural
progression the limit
of this would be X of 1 equals the limit
as n goes to Infinity
of 1 plus r over n
to the nth power
times x naught
and in fact this
is
the definition
of e to the r okay so this is how we
Define this exponential uh this
exponential function e to some power is
literally this expression here that you
would use to find the best way to
compound continuously this is a compound
compounded continuously
your money is always working either for
you or against you I think there's an
Einstein quote that you know uh
something to the effect of you know
understanding the power of exponential
growth and economics is like one of the
most powerful forces in the entire
universe is this kind of exponential
growth of an investment or you know of a
loan okay it's what kind of keeps you
growing or or Sinking and so this is how
we Define this exponential function and
if we just plopped out instead of R here
a rate I just put in one I would get the
number e so e is this expression where R
equals one e to the one equals e okay
one plus one over n to the power n as I
take infinitely many Little Steps n okay
so this is literally what I mean by the
exponential
and again e is Euler's
number Euler is a pretty cool uh pretty
cool mathematician pretty interesting
fellow maybe I'll tell you more about
Euler at some point in the future and I
think he had a lot of children uh
extremely prolific probably one of the
most prolific mathematicians who ever
lived wrote bookshelves of MacBooks I
remember at the Caltech math Library
there was an entire massive stack
dedicated to like all of Euler it was
just all Oiler all the time uh blind in
one eye because he was so serious about
uh his work there was this astronomical
challenge to you know measure some uh
planetary object or some some object in
our solar system and predict where it
was going to be this was like a a you
know Global competition at the time for
fame and fortune and Euler thinking that
someone else was going to get there
first stayed up for three nights in a
row looking through his uh telescope
with one eye and writing down math with
the other like a loon and uh actually
damaged his um his eyesight permanently
he like actually was blind in one eye
after that but he solved the problem won
the prize Fame and Fortune and today we
still remember Euler uh and E is one of
the most important numbers of all in
mathematics okay so this is how we think
of e and Euler's number in terms of
compound interest
I'm going to
just like fire
python script here let's see if I can
plug this in quickly
and we're just going to compute some of
these things to see how this looks you
know what is let's say R equals 0.05
this will just take a moment to pop over
to the right place good
so let's for a moment just say
um where am I going to write this I'm
just going to say
you know let's say
R equals 0.05 so five percent interest
okay that's like approximately what
interest rates are now okay so R equals
five and what we're going to do is I'm
just going to compute these at different
levels of compound so I'm going to
create a new Jupiter notebook file new
notebook python
okay so I'm going to uh import numpy as
NP
because if I don't do that I'm not going
to be able to take the exponential which
is irritating
um okay so first things first I guess
what I'm going to do is I'm just going
to compute you know yearly compound
interest is really simple so R equals
0.05
and you know uh print one plus r
all right so if I compound yearly then
after one year I owe 1.05 times my
initial loan amount let's say I do this
monthly
so I'm going to do uh you know
um
one plus let's say one plus r over 12.
to the 12th power again you use star
star to take something to the the 12th
power in Python
and this is a little bit bigger it's not
a lot bigger but it is
0.116 percent more that's a that's a
very small amount you would barely even
notice it but this is more that the bank
is getting if they compound monthly than
yearly let's say we do this annually one
plus r
over 365 to the power 365.
okay even a teeny bit bigger now instead
of 0.11 percent bigger now it's 0.12
bigger a little bit bigger and if we
keep going into this limit this kind of
AD infinite item limit we should get uh
this e to the R and E to the r is going
to be close to 1 plus r but it's going
to be a little bit bigger okay and I'll
I'll show you that later so e to the r
oh NP dot X of r
remember that's why I had to import
numpy np.x the exponential of R is
1.051271 so this is the best the bank
can do by compounding continuously every
nanosecond compounding continuously this
is the best they can do and again it's
better than annual it's a tiny tiny tiny
bit better than annual it's better than
monthly and it's definitely better than
yearly for them and you might think that
this is a very
uh small amount but I googled this on my
way over here today and it turns out
that the total Global debt at the moment
is 300 trillion dollars that's a huge
number 300 trillion dollars and so the
difference in this you know
0.0001 between even daily and continual
compound interest if you multiply that
by 300 trillion dollars that's not
nothing that's that's a lot of money
okay so smart people have thought about
how to get the most out of these loans
and they came up with this exponential
compound interest okay it
okay
um I'll just give you a couple more
examples because I am here and you are
here and we're both here so
um I mean I guess what we could say is
we could actually write this compound
interest problem down and we could say
um that the loan amount maybe I'll do
this in red because it's not so squeaky
that's very squeaky I'm gonna do this in
yellow the loan amount
uh is continuously increasing the loan
amount X is continuously increasing
continuously
increasing
at a rate
R proportional to the current load
amount proportional this is supposed to
sound familiar proportional
to the current
loan amount
so again this is just like the bunny
population now what we have is
essentially
um and I'm going to write this a few
different ways if this was
um
essentially
DX DT the loan amount X is increasing at
a rate you know D X is changing in time
at a rate R proportional to the current
loan amount so this is exactly what we
had before
and again the solution to this
differential equation is my loan amount
in the future
is e to the r t times my initial loan
amount so after one year X at one year
is e to the r x naught at two years my
loan amount is e to the 2R X naught and
so on and so forth okay and this is
going to grow super duper fast so you
either if you are borrowing money you're
going to borrow more money if you don't
pay it off and it's going to get worse
and worse and worse exponentially or if
you have some money and you invest it
now that's going to grow exponentially
if you get a good rate R okay so this is
a very very powerful powerful concept
again this is a differential equation
and if I was dealing with one of these
uh yearly or or monthly or daily I would
write this as a difference equation I'd
say Delta x equals R times
X of t
times delta T my little time increment
and this would essentially establish a
discrete time update every year or every
month or every day
um it's kind of interesting this
actually should
um
get you thinking back to that bunny
example
in my bunny example bunnies don't
exactly continuously
well maybe somebody's populations do
continuously breed but it might be more
reasonable to think that they have you
know
um annual Cycles where their population
Grows Right like a lot of animals will
have babies in the spring or or
something like that and so maybe my
original Assumption of bunny populations
evolving according to this differential
equation was actually an idealization
maybe they I should set up some you know
annual
um discrete time update for how those
bunnies evolved maybe something more
like you know X at year K plus one so K
this indexes is the year you know my
bunny population at the next year is uh
maybe one plus Lambda
times my bunny population this year that
might be or one plus r times my bunny
population this year so maybe bunnies
are actually more like yearly
compounding if you had a large enough
population so you could average over
those effects you know of uh not being
able to birth continuously and maybe
there weren't
um significant weather fluctuations so
bunnies could have babies whenever they
wanted then maybe this would be better
approximated by that continuous
differential equation so this is a theme
in this class I want you to always be
questioning my assumptions and the
foundations of how I'm you know what I'm
using to derive these equations because
everything you write down in math is an
idealization of the real world and it
really helps to understand what
approximations you're making what
assumptions you're making and how would
you make it more rich and complex and
accurate if you needed to okay
good okay I'm going to erase this I'll
give you kind of one or two more quick
examples and then I'll be done
okay so just a couple more last examples
of this kind of exponential
um behavior from differential equations
uh for this I'm going to talk about
radioactive decay so that's one of my
favorite examples it's really intuitive
we've always heard of this the half-life
of an isotope so Radioactive
decay
so we talked about how bunny populations
grow without bound your loan rate your
loan amount grows without bound forever
radioactive decay is the opposite if I
start with a kilogram of uranium it is
going to actually Decay away to zero
eventually but according to the exact
same differential equation so we're
going to have x dot equals something
that's linear proportional to X
but now it's going to be a minus num
it's going to be a negative
proportionality so so the rate of change
of the the mass let's say
let's say that this is the you know mass
of an isotope
or whatever my radioactive material
uranium plutonium uh
uh you know whatever that's the mass and
the rate of change in my mass in time of
how much plutonium I have left it
decreases if I have a kilogram then it
will decrease at a certain rate
proportional to that as it you know
breaks down and decays okay that's what
radioactive decay is and so similarly I
can write down the solution of this
exit time T is equal to e to the minus
Lambda T times however my and however
much I initially started with let's say
I had like a kilogram of uranium I don't
so don't come
uh come for me
and this e to the minus Lambda t
now this is T and this is X now this
thing is going to have this exponential
decay profile so whatever my initial
amount at Time Zero it's going to Decay
into K into K and decay and whatever
point at which it is half you know one
half of where you started this is what
is called the half-life kind of the the
half-life of that radioactive decay and
different elements different radioactive
elements have different half-lives some
of them are extremely long some of them
are extremely short okay and those have
very very different consequences on your
health on how toxic something is to the
environment so you know there's a lot of
radioactive waste unfortunately in our
world in the current uh era and some of
that radioactive waste is going to be
with us you know for for many many many
many generations of humans because the
radioactive Half-Life is so long because
this is so stretched out it takes
forever for this thing to Decay okay so
for example plutonium
um I believe plutonium
plutonium has a half-life
the half-life of plutonium is 80 million
years that's a really long time so that
means if you start with a kilogram of
plutonium 80 million years in the future
you're going to have half a kilogram of
plutonium left and another 80 million
years in the future you're going to have
a quarter of a kilogram of plutonium
left and that's a long long time to be
you know walking around with a bunch of
plutonium okay it's dangerous stuff and
so we can actually use this formula and
this Half-Life to predict things about
how much I'll have at different times
so if I take my Half-Life that literally
means my initial amount divided by two
that's that's
at some amount of time this is how much
I'll have left so I'm just going to say
kind of
um
X at some T is going to not x to the t x
at some time t
is going to equal this amount
and that's going to be e to the minus
Lambda times that Big T which I'm saying
is 80 million years so that's 8 times 10
to the 7.
X naught and so you could uh you know
fire up Matlab or Python and basically
you know cancel these guys out and say
uh you know e to the minus Lambda times
eight times ten to the 7 equals one half
you log both sides and you would get you
know minus Lambda
equals uh log of one-half
divided by eight times ten to the
seventh so that is actually how you
would compute Lambda from this Half-Life
so if you know the half-life you can
compute Lambda if you know Lambda you
can compute the half-life okay so that's
that's kind of useful
uh and interestingly polonium not
plutonium but polonium polonium
polonium
has a half-life
of closer to 140 days about 140 days
and so this one uh if you remember the
news polonium is is frequently used to
poison political
dissonance dissonance people who don't
agree with you uh because partly because
it actually disappears very quickly okay
so um you know it has a very short
half-life and so it kind of disappears
at a relatively rapid rate okay good
uh other examples of exponential growth
or Decay another one that I really like
is uh thermal Runaway
so thermal Runaway
in electronics
so if you have your computer your CPU or
your GPU it turns out that the hotter it
gets the more resistance it has and the
more resistance it has the hotter it
gets and so this is a big problem in
electronics is that the temperature the
rate of change change of the temperature
of a little chip is actually
proportional to the temperature in that
chip it actually gets hotter faster the
hotter it is and so if you just naively
predicted from this equation you would
say well every piece of electronic
should you know melt down get hotter
than the Sun and eventually you know
create a black hole and swallow the
universe because this is eventually the
temperature is going to go to infinity
and that's you know why doesn't why
doesn't
T go to Infinity
and there's a number of reasons the
first kind of most obvious reason is
that this is just an approximation this
is locally true for little changes in
temperature a little bit more
temperature does make my resistance
higher it does make it get hotter faster
some temperature when my little piece of
electronics is hot enough it starts
radiating to the environment there's
actually something called black body
radiation or Stefan boltzmann radiation
and so this is not exactly true this is
just an approximation at some point
there is a non-linearity that kicks in
this minus t Cube that stops being a
linear differential equation and this is
you know because of radiation
and that kind of uh helps to you know
this is going to grow exponentially so
if I look at my temperature
as a function of time
this thing is going to grow kind of
exponentially for a little while until
this non-linearity gets big and then
it's going to kind of saturate at some
hot temperature where it's it's
radiating as much energy as is being
generated okay so also just good to know
in general that you know these linear
assumptions are often true until they're
not my bunny population May grow
exponentially until they run out of
resources or run out of food or until
wolves or foxes come into the
neighborhood and there's some non-linear
effect you know my loan amount will grow
and grow and grow until you know the
Global Financial system collapses right
there's always these other effects and
so you need to be kind of aware that
this is really an approximation okay
that is my intro to the simplest linear
ordinary differential equation x dot
equals Lambda X next time we're going to
solve this using different methods using
Taylor series and we're going to start
building this up into more and more
complicated differential equations that
model the real world in more Rich ways
soon stay tuned
[Music]
foreign